[Music]
Good day Garm von Silford My name is Cain,
Gracia's third son, and this is just a
story.I was
reincarnated in this other world with my memories of this world.I was
born as an aristocrat, and I can freely enjoy life in this other world.''
That's what I thought, but
it's a prank played by the gods. It would be bad if the world found out about this. You over there
will keep it a secret from everyone.
I'm following the example of Cain's older sister, who
doesn't know much about this child.
I can't help it.As the representative of Cain-loving children,
I'm going
to specially tell you how wonderful
Cain-kun is.Cain-kun is
cute, smart, kind, and
has a talent that surprises even adults.He's amazing.
I'm sure I'll fall in love with you. This
is Santana's Silk Phone. My best
friend Teresa and I have promised to marry Cain.
But Cain quickly becomes friends with other girls.
Chan, you've
been gone for several days without contacting me, and now that I think about it, I wonder
if you forgot about our next date. If you've forgotten, I'll have to make you
sit up straight. Please excuse me. I'm
emailing you. My name is
Sylvia. You're all
members.  Have you already seen his success? I have
been taking care of him since he was a child,
but he is more than a champion, kind, and popular
with girls.As he has
grown to the size of Tripp, he has become more and more popular with
me.  When I think I'm going to leave you inside, please
leave it to God Esport
[Music] I'm
Telestia Terra Etiport, the third princess of the kingdom. The
member is my fiancée. Because of my
fighting spirit, I'm also engaged to Silk, so I'm
not at all worried.  He doesn't care. He
quickly becomes friends with other women, so I'm
really
worried. I guess the members are just as lewd as my father said.
Anime:
Adventures of a Reincarnated Aristocrat in Another World